contrairement à ses habitudes le
pentagone n'a eu de cesse ces derniers
jours et même ces dernières semaines de
communiquer des informations à caractère
tactique le plus souvent d'une grande
précision est presque toujours issu du
renseignement prélevés sur le terrain
puisque une guerre de communication sans
merci se joue entre russes et ukrainiens
aujourd'hui et particulièrement depuis
le début de l'offensive
les communiqués du pentagone devienne
l'une des principales sources
d'information des médias américains en
tout cas pour obtenir une sorte de
vision d'ensemble de la manoeuvre des
armées russes en ukraine ainsi il semble
se confirmer que l'armée ukrainienne
installé en position défensive soit
parvenu à freiner les bataillons
d'infanterie mécanisée russe sur trois
fronts majeurs le front est d'abord à
hauteur de cramât store sq mais
également les fronts nord-est et
nord-ouest à leur jonction aux abords
immédiats de la capitale ukrainienne
kiev la vaste opération aéromobile qui
visait d'une part pour les russes à
s'emparer des infrastructures
aéroportuaires et a désorganisé les
unités d'infanterie ukrainienne sur leur
arrière semble avoir échoué en plusieurs
endroits au point de permettre à l'armée
ukrainienne d'exploiter des images de
capture de soldats russes une guerre de
communication encore une fois qui révèle
également la destruction d'unités
blindées et notamment de chars t 72 et
ce dans des proportions plutôt inattendu
le pentagone expliquent ces succès qu'il
convient néanmoins de qualifier de
provisoire par une défaillance au moins
partielle de la logistique logistique
russe et de l'indispensable coordination
entre des manoeuvres d'artillerie et
d'infanterie enfin et même s'il reste
difficile pour les observateurs de
déterminer si la communication du
pentagone vise à encourager la
résistance ukrainiennes ou si elle
repose sur de réelles informations il
semble que la stratégie d état-major
ukrainien leur ai donné quelques succès
on pense notamment à ce que le pentagone
qualifie de stratégie de harcèlement par
de petites unités ukrainienne équipé
d'armes anti char et procédant à des
embuscades successives sur les route
pénétrante de l'est de l'ukraine
on apprend enfin qu'un peu plus des deux
tiers des forces russes sont entrés en
ukraine soit un peu plus de cent mille
hommes et qu'une prochaine phase
offensive cette fois pourrait intervenir
en provenance de la mer noire et sous la
forme d'opérations amphibies mené par
l'infanterie de marine et des commandos
russe
tout aller